you saw me cry how about this i know i
know what song okay one of my favorite
musicals is annie
and when she's she's in the windowsill
what was like well like when that came
out what do you mean
oh i waited in line and everything i was
19.
i was 19. yeah so i got a job i had a
job in the car and stuff so i went you
know what i mean
there was no online so i just waited in
line for two days wait tell him tell him
the annie song so i wanna hear the annie
song so she's sitting in the windowsill
right yeah
maybe far away
or maybe
real nearby
that song you know that song tomorrow
two maybe do that one that's better yeah
is it that yeah it's not it's not the
same one it's not the same song not the
same song but it's from the same show oh
yeah i like maybe that's a good song let
him do it let him do it all right
the sun will come out
tomorrow
bet your bottom dollar that tomorrow
that's pretty good y'all be sun
just thinking about
tomorrow
there'll be sun
[Music]
the day
gray and lonely
try to stick up my chin
and grin
and sing
tomorrow
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it was really good
can you sing it are there like uh
any like uh san diego songs or no
there's i know some korean songs ah who
would want that oh yeah sing that
only like jason
no no just korean songs let me hear a
korean song this is a real one i don't
know what it means okay and i don't know
how to finish it okay but it's
alex is gonna laugh immediately
is my dad's singing it yeah
so
he would beat me with a [ __ ] golf
club
[Laughter]
with a golf club really yeah yeah
bruises all over my body was [ __ ]
terrible wow one that we
[Laughter]
is
annie you were the one that drove the
car no you were like the
guy you're a man in the house oh look at
that that was his name go ahead send me
something hey look at ah gosh loading up
like like bullets into a cliff he's just
like
like it's loading in his head yeah yeah
it's so good
now we don't have a song yeah
you don't know an indian song to sing
it's gotta be like a lullaby or
something yeah i probably know i don't
really know that many i don't know the
the rap [ __ ] i can't rap i'd be
listening
i think no the old indian [ __ ] from like
you know honey
are you angry right now
i'm wondering why you're so angry i'm
not angry i'm [ __ ] fine with blast
it's a fun time but we're not having a
fun time i think we're having a fun time
having a great time
whenever you look at me i see anger i
don't know i love you dudes right now
but you wouldn't because you're weird
about that stuff
you are a little weird about that
kissing on the lips yeah yeah yeah i'm
on the cheek like yeah i'd do that okay
yeah okay no problem yeah steal it
go ahead steal it because i want to
there you go steal it no problem do both
sides you know okay that's fine
[Laughter]
and i have to say that you don't know
okay okay
okay no but you're way too fast because
i know you're trying to i know you're
trying to kiss me no i'm not
[Laughter]
what do you mean
he sent me his dick i said i love you
and then he just sent me a picture of
his dick that's love that's long that's
not love that's not a cultural thing
okay
oh
[Laughter]
they're like oh that's no no
that looked weird
with his hands here so you wouldn't kiss
him
yeah
okay wasn't that your intention to sneak
a kiss on the lips yeah
i know dude i know i think that's how
that whole thing started kissing that
wasn't a guy was just trying to kiss
another guy and he like turned you just
turned again
he's like oh [ __ ] maybe that's how
that's that's how i was dude
i gotta
i've kissed you on the lips a thousand
five thousand times without like too
many [ __ ] have you guys kissed on the
lips never yeah yeah yeah new york bro
it's new yorkshire you know what it is
seriously because the way that we get
looked at when we do it fine they it
would change a lot of things for this
whole show all right yeah yeah yeah
print two yeah
the two would be back for
sure 100.